president zielenski ukrainian president
speaking live now let's listen him
the information
about our
army's might
and uh successful operations
we we needed
[Music]
need the support of our population trust
me
our army is a my is a military might and
[Music]
our army now is repelling the attacks
during the heavy fighting in donbass in
the south in the east in the north and
uh enemies
uh
sustained
big losses they came to our land
ukraine was attacked from
the north east and the south from the
air and our defense is working
and national solidarity is the main
stalwart of ukrainian statehood
but
i think that
this is not the only thing that we got
we already
uh distributing uh weapons to everyone
who
is ready and willing to
to
defend our
sovereignty every citizen is involved in
the future of our country
anyone who has a military
training who who has a military
experience has to come to the uh
internal ministry
and make yourself available for that to
protect our uh population
from um as of this morning we have
injured uh soldiers
please
uh
give your blood
to
the hospitals uh give your blood to our
defenders
now i want to uh emphasize that this is
a serious work this is a defense
under the present circumstances other
under what's happening from every
entrepreneur uh
you you are responsible um
for our future work
to the good of the whole nation and
people have
people have to have everything in shops
every services that they need national
bank of ukraine and our banking system
they have
every single resource
in order to satisfy the uh financial
needs of the country
to protect the interests of the citizen
of ukraine i am grateful
to uh all uh national uh politicians who
supported ukraine and protect and defend
our independence we don't have the
opponents now among us we're all the
citizens of the beautiful country and we
are fighting for our freedom we're
defending our freedom be prepared to
protect your country on the squares of
your cities and towns
we will
we will believe the sanctions of
every citizen of ukraine who
is ready to
to protect and defend our country with
weapons in their hands uh as a
territorial defense forces
um this morning uh dear friends idea um
citizens this morning
becomes
became history but this history is
different for us
and for russia we broke the diplomatic
relations with russia
ukraine is defending and would not give
its freedom whatever they think in
moscow
you for the ukrainians
in our independence and the right to
live
on our land
to accord in accordance with our will
russia cowardly
attacked our country early in the
morning
very much like the nazi germany uh did
during the second world war
as of today uh countries
on the different side of the world
divide
russian uh federation is on the evil
side
but ev but a lot depends on the russian
people the citizens of russia will be
choosing which path
they are
personally
for everyone who didn't lose their
conscience
in
russia they have to come out and
show their protest against this war
against this war with ukraine
and i want
separately
appeal to the ukrainian citizens and in
russian
for
for the russian people
i know
this information you you're not going to
be
shown in your social media or your tv
channels but blocking this this is evil
this is the wish to
annihilate a nation this is not possible
you cannot block history it's impossible
and
dear
citizens of ukraine are
strong
uh
ukraine some some of you have friends
uh relatives journalists in russia who
knows bloggers please contact them they
have to talk constantly about it then
russia will know the truth this is very
important thank you very much
we will be uh informing you every hour
talking to you
talking with you
talking with our uh population with our
society
and as of now
as of now this is president vladimir
zelinsky